hello Berlin how are you doing I'm
excited to be here well that was kind of
week everybody's still sleeping haven't
had coffee how are you doing
excited to be here there we go there we
go all right I just need to make this
fullscreen so you can actually see it
huh if I could see my cursor all right
so I am here today to talk to you about
CSS in J's and I want to review a little
bit of where we've been where we've come
and where we're gonna go next now for
those of you who don't know who I am my
name is max Tiber I'm at MX stbr
almost everywhere which looks way more
complicated than it is if you remember
my name take out all the vowels you'll
have my Twitter handle
I am from Vienna like they say the
handsome Austrian I work at github which
you hopefully know if you don't know
what gets a [ __ ] then what are you
doing why are you here I'm just kidding
and I'm most well known for creating
styled components react boiler plates
polished and a bunch of other
open-source projects in the react
ecosystem before I dive into the state
of CSS and yes I want to talk a little
bit about how CSS ingest works now if
you've never seen style components this
might look a bit odd but essentially you
write your CSS in JavaScript now this is
true of any CSS and J's library I just
used style components because I made it
so clearly it's the base I'm just
kidding
the way it works is that you write your
CSS in JavaScript and whatever library
you use then goes ahead and creates a
completely unique class name for your
Styles in this case we have a title
component which is a h1 right and as a
heading there is a color of pale violet
red and a font size of 24 pixels now
when that is rendered into the browser
what will happen is it'll create some
CSS for you with a random class name
which is based on a hash of the contents
of the class and it'll assign that class
name to the Dom tag now that's all well
and good but why would you write CSS in
JavaScript how does that make any sense
in those two separate languages well yes
however there's many reasons to like CSS
and yes I personally I have five
specific ones it gives me a lot of
confidence in my code I can add change
and delete any CSS I want and I know
it's only going to affect the single
component that it's next to if I change
the font size of my title components
nothing else will be affected and I can
be sure of that that also leads me to
completely painless maintenance because
I can delete any piece of CSS I can do
any line of styles and I know it's not
gonna happen it's not gonna change the
styling of anything else I can also
completely get rid of a component and I
know that every single line of CSS that
is associated with that component is
deleted I cannot have any dead CSS
anymore zero this is also great for team
work in my teams usually teams aren't
made up of only CSS experts with 15
years of experience in CSS CSS andreas
makes a lot of things impossible you can
no longer have class name collisions you
can no longer have deaths uses you can
no longer have an optimized CSS a lot of
great defaults are baked into these
libraries to make your life easier even
if you have a team with junior
developers that you're mentoring that
might not know CSS inside and out
you'll still you can still be sure that
a certain baseline level of quality will
be achieved with the code now of course
if somebody writes horrible code they're
gonna write horrible code right whether
you use CSS in yes or anything else
really doesn't matter however CSS in gs
gives you a great baseline the fourth
point and I know a lot of people are
gonna be
this one is fast performance
out-of-the-box what I mean by that
specifically is that CSS nsj can keep
track of which components are actually
used on a page so you render a page of
your app you probably have hundreds of
pages if you have a big app and the only
CSS that will be injected is the CSS of
the components that are on the page
nothing else it is automatic critical
CSS out-of-the-box you don't have to do
anything you don't have to use any extra
tooling you don't have to rely on any
detection methods it just works out of
the box because we know which pieces of
Styles you actually use now that is
doubly important for server-side
rendering when you server-side render a
page what happens is we keep track of
which components you use and we put a
style tag at the top of your HTML with
only the Styles of the component that
you actually use which means if you use
server-side rendering and CSS and is
your initial HTML file will be smaller
and I'll paint in the users browser
faster than if you use a CSS file you
also save a network request right
there's no extra network requests or
nothing it's just inline in a style tag
and the fifth one is very easy dynamic
styling right in in my react apps I have
lots of adjustments I have extended
components I have primary buttons and
secondary buttons and tertiary buttons
and joining buttons and delete buttons
whatever right all of these adjustments
are very easy to make we CSS and J's
because I'm just extending components
I'm just working with components and I'm
extending existing ones with new styles
and overriding some of their Styles
where I want to we can also use a global
theme now whenever I say these people
come to me yeah but CSS variables right
we can use CSS variables and they're
also a global theme they are and they're
great I I have no hate against users
variables I love them I think they're a
great addition to language however they
only allow for so much customization
with CSS nsj and a theme I can swap out
whatever part of the CSS I want I can't
just turn off colors I can change the
entire layout I can build a base
component library a design system and
then I can reuse that for many different
websites and style every single one
different
however they're still the same
components under the hood which means I
don't have to recreate every single
little button component mobile
components mash bar component they're
just styled differently a little bit to
fit whatever you want the new website to
do all in all CSS andreas guides you to
the pit of success what I mean by the
pit of success is CSS and J's gets you
in the right direction out of the bat
it's harder to write bad code with CSS
and J's now again it's not impossible of
course if somebody writes horrible code
it's gonna be horrible code but this
isn't just guide you in the right
direction gives you a lot of things out
of the box to ensure that you're less
likely to mess up no I like that because
I always mess up so that saves me a lot
of time a lot of people again when I say
they say yeah but we have a super great
process where it's really in-depth code
review and we use 15 different pieces of
tooling and we can achieve the exact
same thing we don't need seasoned Jason
that's awesome right that's super great
CSS and Jessica's just gives you all of
that out of the box with no extra work
required on your part no extra tooling
nothing you just use CSS and J's and it
has sane and great defaults by default
so let's talk about where we're at I
want to talk a little bit about the
present CSS in J's has taken over the
react world I checked a couple of days
ago and in the last week
60% of react installs also installed in
CSS and J's library of some kind 60%
that's almost a majority of reactant
installs also have a CSS and J's library
that's huge
now that doesn't mean that CSS and J's
is the right thing for your team right
maybe you have a designer that know CSS
inside out but doesn't really know
JavaScript they have never written or
typed in a JavaScript file then CSS
injuries may not be for you but if you
are a team with people who at least
understand the basics of JavaScript then
it can really work and it's worked for a
lot of teams now let's take a look at
where we
came from it all started in November of
2014 when jss was first launched by
oleic who I think is in the audience
somewhere jss was way ahead of its time
at a time nobody'd even heard of CSS and
J's and he had built many of the same
things around to learn more new CSS and
J's libraries into JSS way back in
November of 2014 that's what really all
started GSS has been maintained ever
since it's an awesome library the real
debate around citizen Jas kicked off
when Christopher Seider
at visual who works at on the react team
and Facebook gave it talk in Washington
DC at nations yes and he talked about
how at Facebook they wrote their own
implementation of CSS engineers in order
to make their styling more maintainable
and he gave he went to this tiny
conference in Washington DC's really a
small conference there's maybe 200
people there and he went there and he
gave his talk and it went well and
afterwards his slide tech exploded on
Twitter today it's been seen hundreds of
thousands of times a million people have
seen his slides because everybody was
debating about it what the hell are they
doing why would they do this Facebook
what are you doing but in all actuality
it works well for them in fact the new
Facebook calm that was announced I don't
know half a year ago that still hasn't
launched they built another CSS and J's
library two for internal use and again
debating on it right they're using it
for the new main website that's huge
then in January of 2015 radium was
launched radium was the first CSS and
J's library like a really popular
they used CSS and J's via inline styles
so you would write your Styles in
JavaScript and it would assign style
tags to all of your Dom elements now
that approach with the benefit of
hindsight we know is not the best one
and it isn't the best one because a lot
of things you can do in CSS are very
hard to do in a style tag you can't have
pseudo selectors pseudo elements media
queries none of that works so they try
to hack around it by for example
pretending that hover works with
JavaScript event listener so they would
listen for muscle
and mouse out and stuff like that and
assign the hover styles but nowadays we
know their bail approaches however
radium really was the first library to
take this concept and make it more
popular than was before then in February
of 2015
Jackson Brent Jackson launched rebase
again another great library the rebase
isn't technically a CSS and J's library
however it was the first liability that
introduced this CSS components API so
you have a box component for example or
a Flex component and on those components
you can write your CSS as props so you
write books and then you have font size
12 pixels or whatever now since February
of 2015
rebase has come a long way they're now
in version 5 it's still very actively
maintained and in fact we use it on all
of our projects I use it on all of my
projects I should say rebase is awesome
and it makes very it mixes very well
with any other CSS solution you use then
in May of 2015 we got CSS modules now
CSS modules is not technically a CSS NGS
library right with CSS modules you still
write your CSS in a CSS file like it
used to
however I put them in this timeline
because they really popularized this
concept of hashing class names and
giving you unique class names for your
Styles out of the box so you no longer
have any class than mismatches and
without them I don't think many people
would have got man but they sort of
provided a stepping stone and made it
made it possible to have the same
experience without having to put your
CSS in JavaScript see that's what it's
again still great still awesome still
used by many people I love them they're
out there great then in September of
2015 we got C SJS by Ryan tau now this
is a tiny library it's no longer
maintained but it was the first one to
let you write actual CSS in JavaScript
one where you roll your CSS code in
strings in your JavaScript files now
citizen J's eventually turns into a
different library which we'll get to
however it's really that was the first
time anybody thought of actually writing
actual CSS before that everything was
object you always wrote your CSS as a
big JSON object in October of 2015 then
Khan Academy announced aphrodite their
own CSS and J's solution
civically optimized for their
performance needs it was really the
first CSS JS library that proved that
you could have automatic critical CSS
built into a CSS in J's library and that
the library itself made that possible
in June of 2016 Robyn who I think might
also be in the audience
released fella fella is a great library
again still maintains to be used but
lots of people still awesome that was
really the first one to focus in and
holiness concept of style is a function
of state just like react popularized
your view is a function of state fail
popularized your style is a function of
state which actually worked super nicely
with the react component model in July
of 2016 so loop I who is now on the
react team at Facebook released glamour
and what glamour really did he didn't
have any novel api's however it really
focused on performance and it
popularized a very obscure Dom API
called insert rule insert rule is a
really unknown Dom API before that most
CSS and JS libraries simply created a
style tag and set its text content from
JavaScript however that approach isn't
the fastest with insert rule you can
insert up to a hundred thousand rules of
CSS so a rule is like a font size 12
pixels right you can insert up to a
hundred thousand rules of CSS in less
than 16 milliseconds which is
ridiculously fast
when are you ever gonna have a hundred
thousand lines of CSS right that's
insane so glamour really popularized the
API now I hear I gotta give a shout out
to ollie again with j SS because J SS
had been using that API since November
of 2014 which is incredible
absolutely incredible then in October of
2016
J sextile was released by pete hunt one
of the ex react team members who then
families on start a bank or bought by
twitter again still a great library they
still uses and what chase X that we did
is it took this CSS components API a
step further and it went all the way you
can essentially style your entire
application with a box component and put
any kind of CSS into its props again a
great API if that's what you like
geotextile is awesome rebase
Oh awesome also in October of 2016 I
stood on stage and react Netherlands and
I announced style components to the
world this was the first time anybody
had seen this API we really popularized
this is the outer div API now I gotta
give a shout out to fellow because they
actually had a very similar API long
before us however staff components went
ahead and it sort of popularized this
concept of not even ever using class
names before style components every
serious injury library sort of returns
an object of class names and you can
assign that to your Dom times with style
components you're never even touching
any class names anymore they're not
there you're just creating components
that are styled and then you're using
them throughout your application and
side component was really the first
library to go in that direction then
December of 2016 we got style Tron that
is the follow-up library to see SJS the
one that introduced strings of CSS in
JavaScript style Tron made by Ryan Chow
at uber and they still use it today is
still great style Tron really honed in
and focused even more on performance and
what style Shawn did was they created a
unique class name for every single rule
of CSS atomic CSS if you've ever used
tachyons if you've ever used a library
like that this is exactly the same
except you don't have to worry about
remembering any class names you write
your CSS like you always would and they
automatically output atomic CSS to keep
your total CSS sides as minimal as
possible right at a certain point
there's only so many unique rules your
CSS stylesheet has right so the chances
are pretty high that if they output at
atomic CSS the total size is going to be
smaller as if then if they injected a
separate class name for every component
we also go out style checks in December
of 2016 starch SX popularized this sort
of easy entry with a style tag like API
so in your choice X you just write a
style tag and put class names in there
and those class names can refer to any
other element in the same component and
statue Asics will make sure to make all
of the class names unique and stuff like
that just like any other CSS and J's
library this is great for easy entry
it's the same as if you were to write
CSS in HTML right just a style tag with
some Styles even super nice in March of
2017
astroturf was announced at the time it
was called CSS literal loader
but they eventually renamed it to
astroturf and what astroturfed is is
introduced the first class support for
CSS extractions with astroturf you write
your CSS in a JavaScript file and they
have a build process that takes that
JavaScript and puts it into a CSS file
so you're no longer injecting any CSS
from JavaScript it's all extracted use
the same authoring experience with the
same developer experience as you will
have with for example styled components
or glamour or any of these other CSS and
J's library however in the end you just
get a standard class CSS file with
randomized class names that you can then
distribute wherever you want and load
however you want in April of 2017 Kent C
Dodds announced glamorous a package that
is now deprecated at the time it was the
first one to you to implement the styled
components API but with objects and he
really popularized C's writings he says
his objects again so we went full circle
we started with CSS objects then we went
to actual CSS and then we went back to
Caesar's objects nowadays almost all
serious intense library support both or
many of them do I would say for example
stock components nowadays also supports
CSS as objects which is why
Kent C Dodds eventually deprecated
glamorous because he didn't want to
maintain it anymore
in May of 2017 I announced style
components v2 and the really important
point about style components v2 is not
style components it's that we used a new
CSS parser and that CSS parser is called
stylus before that everybody sort of
hacked around the hostess's parsing
thing in fact style components the first
version it took post CSS it ripped out
all of the node parts and then it
shipped that in the browser which is in
I don't understand why we did that at
the time if we had a huge panel size but
stylus some guy in Africa
wrote a tiny CSS partial implementation
in JavaScript it's three kilobytes
military's fully featured CSS parser and
it's SuperDuper fast so we switch to
stylus and nowadays almost every single
CSS and J's library use the stylus
because it's solid it's fast and it's
small the stylus really made a lot of
the performance gains that have been
happening over the past two years
possible without it we probably still
happy having huge bundle sizes and not
as fast as performances we have nowadays
in July of 2017 emotion was announced
and
what emotion we did is it kicked off a
performance competition they went oh so
we rebuilt our components but it's much
smaller and much faster than every other
CSS and J's library so every other CSS
engines Larry went crap now we gotta go
fast too and so everybody started
working on performance they started
focusing on performance and for that the
whole ecosystem is better off now all
this is a some JS libraries are 10 times
faster than they were two years ago all
of them and - pretty much all the same
speed now it doesn't even matter anymore
which is awesome in September of 2017
satya then announced lean area we think
is also in the audience somewhere
lots of SEOs I said yes people here I
just realized that's awesome
linaria took the concept of Astroturf
introduced in extracting the CSS - CSS
file and took it even further it allows
you to write the style components like
API and use from the dynamicism and then
they would still be able to extract it -
in static CSS file this is also a very
popular library - used by many people
and it's awesome
in November of 2018 we then got emotion
v10 emotionally 10 like call it out
because it really popularized using the
CSS prop so kind of similar to the to
rebase and Jacek style you would write
your CSS on every single tag that you
rolled every single JSX tag that you
wrote however rather than using it as
props you have one single prop the CSS
prop and you would just write your CSS
in there
in fact they introduces and afterwards
everybody stole it style components now
also support for the CSS for because it
is a great API and then very recently in
June of 2019 Frank Jackson the guy who
made rebase and a bunch of other stuff
really announced
team UI team UI really went and went a
step further and said ok we now have
control over your CSS how can we make
your CSS even better and what they did
was they enforced consistency by laying
by only letting write styles that are in
a global theme so you have a defined
font size scale if you design design
spacing scale you have color system and
you can only use values from that system
which means your entire application will
always be consistently styled which is
especially important for design systems
now as you hear me talk about all these
things that were launched
you'll notice something I love him all
right I don't discriminate any of them I
made South components now I think South
components is the best clearly but to be
honest with you it really doesn't matter
all of these libraries are great and the
reason they're all great is because we
all copied everything from each other
somebody came along and had a new idea
somebody came along and had any a new
invention and they went and they built a
life before it and they announced didn't
they talked about it and then every
other citizen just like we went aha
we should also do that and so they just
copied everything from each other and
again I have no hate all of these people
are my friends right I'm great friends
with all of them I love every single one
of their libraries we constantly talk
with each other and this entire
ecosystem is only as good as it is
because we're all working together to
get better all together now where do we
go from here what's the future of CSS
and J's and the honest answer is I don't
know I have absolutely no idea which is
why we need you to create the future of
styling react apps if you working on
react apps I'm sure you've struggled
with CSS before I'm sure you've
struggled with obscure bugs if you use
CSS in chess
I'm sure you've struggled with it too
there's always some edge cases if you
have any ideas if you have any in in if
you have any ideas if you have any new
things that you want to try a new API is
you think that could work try it out
just try building a ship a prototype
make it prototype make it work and then
share it with the world
right because we only got here because
we all tried something new we all put
our head out there and said I have an
idea
it maybe sounds kind of stupid but I
think it could work it feels kind of
nice what do you think I want you to do
the same thing we're not done yet right
we're not at the maximum we're not
perfect we're not at the finish line
not even close it's been four years
right we have 50 years more to go
hopefully with react at least I hope so
now how do you actually do this how do
you if you have an idea how you go from
I have an idea for an API to sharing it
with the world and making it popular
there's three tips I have for you the
first one that is that you have to do it
in an order you first have to make it
work then you have to make it right and
then you have to make it fast what that
means is we start components we had this
weird idea for this weird new API that
nobody's ever seen or heard and we
thought about it and we thought maths
could be kind of nice let's try it we
build a super Hacket prototype where we
should post CSS to the browser and we
just tried it and then we used it to
build our own personal web sites and we
were like hah this feels awesome Wow
and so we launched it we announced it
the first version again technically
speaking was horrible much worse than
the newest version of stalkin what is
much worse however it worked it proved
that building this API was feasible and
it made people aware that it was
possible and since then we've then made
it right we start Cummins v2 v3 and v4
we worked on making it right we really
focused on adding API so you could do
anything to do with CSS in CSS and yes
we focused on making the developer
experience nice we focus on having nice
error messages we focus on all of these
things that in a prototype you don't
really want and then we worked on making
it fast since version 3 we've really
focused on performance and in fact style
components is gotten faster and faster
and faster with every single release and
nowadays it's one of the fastest
libraries out there the second tip I
have for you is that you should share it
early and share it often again the first
version of style component we announced
it was a horrible hack right nobody
should have used it but it proved the
point and it got people talking and we
were talking to people who were like
yeah this looks nice but how do I make
global stars happen yeah this looks nice
but how do I use media queries how do I
use pseudo selectors how do I do
multiple components how do i extend
stuff and through these conversations
style components got better we learned
things we knew what people wanted we
knew what was missing and we could work
on making it better so sharing early and
sharing often is super critical in fact
if you do get around to building your
dream CSS and J's library ping me on
Twitter and I will share it with
everyone to get your feedback I'll be
super excited about that at the third
and very important point is that you
really need to document all the things a
big part of why react boilerplate and
style components got
popular is because they were very
well-documented I spent way more time
writing documentation for them then I
actually creating the projects and
projects themselves documentation is
super vital to make sure that your users
know how to do everything they need with
your thing for react boilerplate that
meant documenting how react works how
Redux works our redux Agha works how all
these technologies that we used work for
style components that means how do you
do all the things that you do with CSS
how do you do
again pseudo selectors pseudo elements
media queries adapting based on props
extending all of these things need to be
documented and explained and shown so
the users know how to work with your
library documentation is critically
underused you need to write a lot of
documentation I spent again way more
time writing documentation than actually
writing than actually writing code
alright I hope this was an interesting
overview over the CSS interests library
library ecosystem again if you have any
ideas please build a prototype send it
to me I'll look at it I'll share it I'll
give you feedback we need to get better
we're not done yet
please keep at it that's all I have for
you today thank you and I hope you enjoy
the rest of the conference
[Applause]
you